both of these answers by the way
different that's kind of weird
um you can prove this identity by the
way that set plus tan equals one plus
tan x on two
on one minus tan x on two it's not that
hard to prove
but there's one thing missing off both
of them which is this now i'll freely
admit
i've been kind of floating over this
idea but
i should formalize it now really this is
how we should write things
okay now put your pens down as i explain
this and this will be the last thing
because we're running out of time
you need to understand what's going on
here okay one of my pet hates
is people who uh have learned that when
you integrate
and you have a log okay you just put
absolute value signs on i remember the
first time i asked someone
why do you put absolute value signs on
the answer i got back
was well logs right you can only take
the log of a positive number
can't you it's log base e and there's no
power that you can raise e
to which will give you a negative number
and that's what logs are about right
what powershot raised to
okay and so here's the answer i was
given
you put the absolute value signs on to
make it positive because we want it to
be positive
now i sort of bought it at the time
right that's a really terrible argument
when you think about it
it's like i put absolute value signs on
this is what the argument boils down to
because i want them to be absolute
values like there's no actual
rationale for why it actually makes
sense why you can go from here to here
and it's um actually you need to include
the the absolute values to make sense of
half of your answers okay so let me show
you why
rule off where you've done this answer
because this is an important sub id on
its own
we make statements at integration based
on differentiation
right statement to it um wait does that
say the right way stem is that
integration based on differentiation
so things about logs right well i can
say that the derivative
of log x is equal to one on x can't i
um we've been doing inverse functions
recently and in those trig functions
and we know that something that you can
normally not worry about but sometimes
is really important
is restrictions there is a restriction
on this isn't there what's the
restriction
x is positive right
of course it has to be log x doesn't
even exist when x is negative but this
does
how does that make sense it doesn't
that's why you must restrict okay
so on the basis of this statement i can
form an integral of this namely the
integral of one over x
is a log plus a constant no problems
okay
ah but log x has a brother which
is defined for negative values of x
right
namely log of negative x
he's defined for x is less than zero
right
what is the derivative of log of
negative x
well you do chain rule right you do the
inside function so you go
that's minus one right and then you
divide by
well it's f dash on f isn't it
huh what just happened i'll tell you
what happened
a restriction happened okay
so what this means is i made a um an
integral statement on the basis of
this derivative in this domain i'm going
to do the same
thing here watch carefully right it's
the same
integral 1 over x dx right but it
doesn't
end up on log x if you're in a different
domain it only ends up on log x in this
domain
right if you're not in that domain
you end up here i'm just going backwards
right just follow the argument right
so in this domain you get this log in
this domain you get this log
and they're different right but i can
combine them
i can say therefore this integral
is equal to two different things
depending on where you are okay
it's equal to log x plus c provided
x is positive okay but
it's equal to log of negative x plus
your constant
if x is negative okay ah
but this here by def this is the way we
define the absolute value function right
the absolute value function is equal to
x when x is positive
and it's equal to minus x negative x
when x is negative
right so therefore i can well these into
one
like so okay so
please please please please please when
someone asks you you know maybe one of
your
three friends is looking over your
shoulder and be like why have you got
absolute values there i don't have to
worry about those
okay don't tell them it's because logs
have to have a positive value that's not
true
this is the reason why right it's
because when you consider under a
different domain when you restrict it in
a different way
you get a whole different function and
this is our way of writing
both okay so that's why when you have
something like this you should have your
absolute value signed today